Build it.
Draw it.
Play it.
Vsauce!
Kevin here with some of the coolest creations
from extraordinary people.
This is BiDiPi.
Build it.
The Smith Mansion in Wyoming is a one-of-a-kind
log structure built by hand by one guy.
Francis Lee Smith spent over 12 years building
the 75 foot high mansion without any blueprints
and he actually died from a fall during its
construction.
Abandoned for over 20 years a preservation
project is currently trying to restore the
incredibly unique house.
Klaus Kemp is the only living practitioner
of diatom arrangement.
Diatom are microscopic single-cell algae that
create glass shells around themselves.
Although popular during the Victorian period
none of these professional microscopists passed
down their techniques.
So Kemp spent eight years researching different
glue to perfectly arrange diatoms.
And he’s constantly searching for new specimens
to meticulously and obsessively build into
arrangements.
Draw it.
Phil Hansen made a portrait of Nikola Tesla
by drawing with electricity.
Hansen developed permanent nerve damage after
an obsession with pointillism and now utilizes
his jittery hands to constantly reinvent ways
to make his art.
Including creating Jimi Hendrix out of 7,000
matches or Chuck Norris with paintballs.
SharpWriter creates over-the-top U.S. presidential
portraits blending sci fi, mythology, and
history.
The exaggerated depictions draw amplify their
personalities such as FDR’s wheelchair becoming
a Transformer, JFK hunting aliens on the moon
or Ronald Reagan riding a raptor.
Because he did that.
Getting a head start on Halloween here's some
spooky art from Billy Ludwig.
Evil Vinyl is a passion project by animation
studio A Large Evil Corporation - transforming
cult classic icons into vinyl toys.
Including, David Brent from The Office, Spinal
Tap and The IT Crowd.
Personally, I really love Ted, Jack and Dougal
from Father Ted.
Play it.
Player Piano pays tribute to Akira with this
awesome rendition of Kaneda's Theme.
The music video for Young by Air Review brings
to life the stock historical footage artwork
of Joseba Elorza.
Finally, Tycho - SEE was shot in complete
darkness with a Microsoft Kinect projecting
an infrared dot pattern - and it was directed
by the ridiculously awesome Bradley Munkowitz.
Inspiration also comes from you.
Vsauce.
Creative.
Fan.
Showcase.
First up is M-Cubed with Magnetism which you
can download for free in the links below.
Let’s go.
ThePatchmakerPlus creates 100% homemade iron-on
and sew-on patches.
Their Etsy store has everything from Winnie
The Pooh To Scooby Doo.
ADCArt paints custom hats and shoes with pop
culture characters.
He’s ridiculously prolific creating new
pieces nearly every day.
Oliver built a homemade motorized bike by
using a 79cc harbor freight clone engine on
a Huffy Walmart bicycle frame.
It took Valentin about eight weeks to build
this steampunk clock.
He built it for a short film using scrap metal,
old clock parts, gearbox, copper sheets, brass
profiles and wood.
Here’s theKHUE with Symmetry.
Sara Sandoval uses stencils and spray paint
for this big canvas painting - check out the
YouTube channel SimplySaraArt for more.
NoAnchorTV made a short doc on how Parkour
saved the life of Casey Jones.
Emil Dahl is a world class juggler and known
for being the first to ever juggle nine clubs.
Submit your BiDiPis to me BiDiPi@Vsauce.com
or share them with everyone on Twitter with
hashtag #BiDiPi.
And as always - thanks
for watching!